I'm Nancy wing professor of Nursing at
Columbia University and I'm going to the
transit project transit stands for
trained nurse scientists and
interdisciplinary and translational
research we want our students who
represent the community locally as well
as internationally my name is Olivia
Velez I'm a doctoral student in school
nursing and I'm specializing in nursing
informatics my name is Kendrick quedo
I'm in the ph.d program for clinical
informatics I'm a huge cheetah and I am
a geriatric nurse practitioner and a
second year PhD student my name is
Robert Lee Sarah I'm an assistant
professor of Nursing here at the
Columbia University School of Nursing
before I became a nurse as a programmer
and I was infantry officer I moved to
the state's when I was three years old
I'm originally from Japan my mother is
an immigrant from Spain my dad is a 2nd
generation mexican-american I was born
and raised in New York the ph.d program
at Columbia has been transformed to
refocus our training and our course
content to provide the best possible
signs of the background from nurses who
are going to become the leaders as your
scientists in the 21st century I was
looking for a really research intense
program and Columbia had a reputation
for interdisciplinary collaboration when
I came back from Iraq I was talking to a
friend of mine who was a nurse and I
actually started taking pre-med classes
and she said you know have you ever
thought of becoming a nurse
well I was completing the nursing
program I met professor who specializes
in nursing informatics and I became
interested in it I learned early on that
the key to success is making certain
that I had other senior scientist
mentoring me they have some of the world
class internationally known
neuroscientist investigators here at
Columbia who will be your networking we
have world-renowned nurse scientist and
informatics and epidemiology and Health
Services Research and in women's health
I'm studying with dr. Suzanne Bakken and
she's considered not only one of the
leaders in nursing informatics but in
the hall informatics field I feel very
blessed very excited to be able to study
with her because I don't see a great
scientist but she's also a great mentor
and I'm really looking forward to that
because of her areas of interest and I
think that's sort of tired me up my
mentor has an open door policy I know
that I can go to her with any questions
when I interviewed with her I knew right
away that we had this connection we are
bad ringing and
part of our community the great thing
about relationships between students
here is that we have this strong bond we
all help each other get through this
program I mean it's an intense program
since it's a graduate program there
aren't hundreds of students we all start
together we study together we go out
together we all know each other's
families you make great friendships you
make great connections if you have a
passion and the excitement and the
interest and the ability we are here to
make sure you become a partner with us
and one of our graduates and then new
york city itself is a classroom it's the
biggest city in the united states and
why would you go anywhere else i love
love the area i love the closest to the
water i love the culture love the food
if you enjoy the nightlife there are a
lot of things you can do it's hard to
explain how great New York is and so
much to see so much to do but it's all
here for you take a look at our website
you do cover tuition for the course work
here contact us ask questions we're
really excited to meet you
you